The joe rogan experience,
there's,
there's some great good to exposing these things.
But in doing so,
the overzealous approach of accusing all men of being potential rapist is an
adjust just an overreaction.
And then won't it balance itself out?
Do you or do you think that it's more complicated than that?
It's gonna.
It's gonna Backfire because the problem looks like a power grab.
But won't the backfiring balance itself out?
I mean people,
reasonable people like you or myself or we're always going to recognize the
difference that there are monsters.
Yes.
Right.
And we're not going to deny monsters because someone goes too far in the accused
garrison Keillor of being a monster when we know that that's not true.
It doesn't make sense.
The story doesn't make sense.
So because most people who I've talked to about the garrison Keillor story,
which he was consoling a woman and he touched her back and then she pulled back
and he apologized and I didn't mean to do that.
And then he sent her an email apologizing and she said,
no big deal.
Don't worry about it.
They were good for awhile.
And then years later,
right when all this me two things,
she just decides,
I remember something that was wrong and let's,
let's take this guy down,
like with just,
which didn't make any sense that,
first of all,
well let's leave it alone.
Didn't make any sense.
But where's garrison Keillor now?
Right.
Yeah.
He hasn't been resurrected.
It hasn't been resurrected.
They took his shows off the air.
It doesn't make money.
So it aside,
you know,
whether or not you like him as an artist or creator,
just like they actually destroyed not just him,
but his legacy for a hug,
for something that at the time both parties agreed was no big deal.
Yeah.
I just saw,
I don't understand it.
I don't,
it's completely unacceptable and it's the death of justice.
Well,
was that just getting caught up in the hysteria of just like trying to find
Todd?
There's one put that fire out immediately.
Um,
so we have a couple of problems and one of the problems is that the folks who
are advancing this movement and the other parallel,
I wished they hadn't taken the term social justice because,
um,
we need a replacement term for that.
That is,
uh,
not overzealous.
But those movements have engaged in a kind of naive,
um,
conclusion making that makes them,
uh,
inevitably hijack.
They get inevitably hijacked by bad actors.
So if you,
you are essentially looking at a situation,
if you say,
um,
we must believe all victims,
that's like putting out a neon sign for bad actors that wish to utilize this
structure,
right?
So,
um,
and there will be bad actors.
Yes.
Every population male is a population of females,
a population.
They're monstrous males who have been behaving predatorily.
There will be women who will take advantage of this and accused people without
reason.
I mean,
we,
I don't know whether the numbers are robust or not,
but I've heard numbers that somewhere between 1% to 4% of the population are
sociopathic.
If you set up a system in which we are obligated to believe every victim,
then those people will come out of the woodwork and they will use this to level
their enemies.
And so at the very least,
what that tells you is rule number one,
you cannot make the rule,
you must believe all victims or you will have lots of people piling into the
category of victim that don't deserve to be there.
And who is hurt most by that?
Not only the people who are going to be sabotaged by bad actors,
but the people who have suffered the worst,
um,
cases of rape,
they are effectively having the terrible things that have happened to them
diluted by stories that are either fictional or minor that are being lumped in.
So it's further victimization of them.
It is,
it's a transfer of wellbeing from the people who have been most harmed to people
who've been less harmed or our cynically using,
um,
the structure.
So if,
uh,
the idea of a me too of the reckoning that has finally come for these really
terrible guys who were getting away with all of this awful stuff.
If that is close to your heart,
then what you should want is a set of rules that is careful enough and robust
enough that we can keep holding those kinds of people to account what will
happen if we don't do that.
And I promise you this,
from a game theoretic perspective,
if we decide you must believe all victims and all transgressions are equally
bad,
we're going to turn the thing to 11 for everything from that to happen.
I agree with you.
But how did that happen?
If you're,
if you're cynical kind of nuance in part.
Yeah,
it is.
It is,
uh,
the death of nuance because if you're wielding this thing as a weapon,
right?
If you have,
what you want to do is turn the tables on all men.
If you want to take power and say you listen,
well,
this is a frightening weapon.
So in order to make that weapon maximally dangerous,
you,
um,
you equate you lower with call.
Yeah.
You,
you say it's all one.
Uh,
there's nothing a woman could ever do that would increase her likelihood of
facing any of this.
And you know,
we should cover that in a second because that's one of the,
it's another one of these booby traps where,
um,
you can very easily say the wrong thing and suddenly,
uh,
you're on the defensive even though what you said is very rational.
But it also,
it denies the reality of what Male,
female relationships look like when they're at all healthy.
There's going to be risk.
There is risk as you get to know people.
And I don't,
you know,
we're just meeting say instead of having met in high school so many years ago,
I don't know if I like you yet.
You don't know if he liked me yet.
We're going to take some chances and maybe you're going to say something wrong
and I'm not going to be thrilled with it.
Are you at fault?
Do I?
Do I blame you?
Do I cry?
Harassment?
Because you said something that didn't quite fall right on my ears or did it
sound right and I kind of like you anyway.
And so I go like,
oh,
that's,
that's fine.
You know,
we're good.
Well,
it really depends on,
you know,
how it,
how I receive that depends a lot on how I feel about you.
Otherwise you could say exactly the same words and you know,
you could say it and someone else could say it.
And from that guy I might feel like,
I kind of wish you hadn't said that,
but that has to mean that that isn't big deep problem that he said it because
we're engaged at something where we're trying to discover do we like each other,
are we into each other?
Like what's going on here?
So the process of discovery is going to involve mistake and risk and,
and even some sort of its,
its game playing.
You know,
you're involved in the social game in which you're trying to figure out who each
other are and after the fact saying that guy is kind of gross.
So the thing that he said was Harris Smith,
sorry.
No,
not,
not acceptable.
It's changing the rules of the game based on whether or not you liked a
particular individual and that's not a legit move.
So we,
we gotta be super careful here.
Yeah.
Um,
one thing that is true is we are facing a landscape in which
we are,
I think effectively rewriting the rules of,
um,
male,
female interaction in order to make sex with strangers perfectly safe.
Now,
sex with strangers can't be perfectly safe in a world in which you're dealing
with,
let's say it's 1% sociopath's you can,
they can't make a world in which it's safe to take a sociopath home and have sex
with them,
right?
That that's not going to happen.
But in order to try to make it safe,
we're going to turn up all of these protections.
So for example,
um,
we've got the issue of affirmative consent.
Now,
affirmative consent is a great fail safe in a circumstance where you are dealing
with a stranger.
It seems like it would be absolutely essential because the danger of a
miscommunication is so great that you have to be perfectly explicit and there
can be,
there's no room for,
uh,
any coyness or subtlety about it.
In other words,
it has to effectively be transactional.
No courtship that's going to make it into the history books or literature is
going to involve affirmative consent at every stage.
You can do it.
Yes.
How about now?
Yeah.
Did you remember
that video that they released?
There was a video that,
boy,
I don't remember who did it,
but as essentially showing how consent can be sexy and so,
uh,
it shows this millennial couple making out and uh,
like every few seconds the guy has to ask the girl if it's okay if he kisses
her,
if it's,
is it okay if I touch you here?
Is it okay if I take your shirt off?
And she says not yet.
And then they keep going and going and going and then the,
the girls asking the guy,
which is hilarious,
is it okay if I do this?
Like what?
Because this is magic.
Right?
Exactly,
exactly.
Which is the phosphorus,
right?
Well that was also an issue with,
um,
they've sort of abandoned this,
but a few years ago there was this thing where if you had sex with someone and
alcohol was involved,
you raped them because they could not consent.
But then like,
well,
that means I've been raped a lot of times because that's ridiculous.
Like it did,
but it never worked that way.
It does.
If you want symmetry,
you would have to say that if a man has consumed alcohol and the woman hasn't,
than the woman is raping the man.
I don't want to freak you out.
But,
um,
Heather and I have been assuming each other's consent for 30 years.
I mean,
we have inferred it from cues that were not verbal.
It guys didn't discuss.
What about radio writing things down?
Do you have a chalkboard or,
no,
I mean,
and the thing is the only thing that keeps us safe from being arrested for this,
right?
The board.
We've both done it.
It's like damn right.
You're both criminals.
Yeah.
But this,
this,
these changing,
these shifting of the rules.
It's a,
it seems like it's almost like you were talking about game theory.
It does.
It really does seem like a type of game.
It is life.
But it is a thing where people are looking to call people out.
You're,
you're looking to score,
you're looking to like score.
Uh,
you're,
you're finding someone who's done something inappropriate or finding someone who
doing done something that used to be appropriate but is no longer,
and we're looking to establish this new parameter and this new way of existing
and that there's this,
it takes on this competition element,
which I'm very familiar with.
I understand competition,
so when I see it clearly and I see like teen behavior,
I'm like,
well,
I see what's going on here.
This is not rational thinking.
This is someone who's trying to score points.
You're trying to get one on the board.
Yes.
It's absolutely competitive and it's mostly competitive at the moment.
It looks like second,
if within women and it's going to destroy,
it's actively making male female relationships.
Impossible to navigate.
But I understand it for as a man,
I get the motivation.
I think that women overwhelmingly have been victimized as opposed to like men
being victimized by women in that regard.
In terms of being sexually harassed,
it's not even close.
I mean is it was one of the most unbalanced things in our culture ever.
Completely.
Right.
But it's posted in our culture,
right?
This is what we're talking,
right.
What do we want out of this now?
Now that it's,
but,
right.
Do you want 100%
safety?
Right.
Do you want to maximize safety at the cost of oil?
We have to kill sociopath,
so I want to do that.
Yeah.
The point is if you want,
if you want absolute safety,
I mean we're,
we're getting to the point where this is just robbing.
Okay.
If the point of this is to make sex safe because it's pleasurable,
this is going to rob all over the pleasure from sex.
I mean,
it's,
it's getting to the point where you'd be crazy to have sex without witnesses.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Um,
but,
but anyway,
the point is now that the stuff is on the table right now that we've,
we know that there are monsters.
We know that there are economic forces that actually protect these monsters,
which frankly is a big part of this story.
Hmm.
Right.
Is that the economic structure of something like Hollywood causes this to
continue with it being effectively an open secret that these people are abusing
women and then silencing them and contractually obligating them,
uh,
not to,
to do anything about it.
That,
that,
that cancer on the social system is now open for discussion and we,
all of us decent folk know that we have to get rid of it.
If you get rid of it though,
on false pretenses,
I promise you the very same game theory that caused it to happen in the first
place will cause it to reemerge.
The only,
the reason it makes it harder to address the next time.
Yeah.
Okay.